[Music]
and Magnus Carlsen seals the deal with a
draw he makes it to the final to defeat
a World Cup for the first time ever and
what a game this has been with abasov
finding his chances within the end with
Precision it ended in a draw despite
losing the match what a tournament this
has been for nejat abasov it is the end
of the road but definitely a milestone
and a lot to be proud of with Magnus
using his pawns to distract the bishop
away and the white king ended up coming
backwards the check but now the black
king just goes towards the pawn as we
said before gluing itself to the pawn
and there is glued to the pawn and it
keeps on the pawn
we have this position on the analysis
board pretty much with B3 being played I
think we had this exact position and the
problem here is
the bishop
has to remain on that pawn with any
winning chances but then the king
remains in that pawn as soon as the
bishop moves away well of course there's
many ways to draw here King takes Pawn
is enough but uh they get a draw in well
they play on a little bit here but they
get a draw King versus King at the end
there so